[Music]  i think it's going to be even more  important to have the widest range  of skill sets that you could have so  less specialization more  a  jack-of-all-trades including  design  design thinking design work uh together  with with that programming experience um  and uh so that you can jump into  the new technological advances that are  being made every day you know we're  going to be so much more  in virtual reality can you not just use  it but can you program it i think the  most important ones will be  curiosity and keen eyed observational  skills  see curiosity fuels the question why  which is an essential part of every  innovation and keen observational skills  allow us not to waste our efforts  reinventing the wheel life has already  solved so many of the toughest problems  that the world can possibly throw in it  so why not figure out how biology has  overcome an obstacle and adapt or  improve on that